day breaks over the lovely forested
south rim of the canyon
lighting up a dead pine that would seem
to have little purpose but this pine is
the Central Bank and Trust of the Acorn
woodpecker and every inch is studded
with neatly arranged holes the
woodpeckers safe-deposit boxes finding
the absolutely perfect little vault for
every acorn can be quite the puzzle each
hole has been drilled to fit a certain
nut shape
keeping the treasure house secure
requires a bonding of the birds a
breeding collective of several males and
females along with their extended family
who make deposits and stand guard
[Music]
they can be little gymnasts when threats
come from above simply skittering to the
underside of the bank branches
this is just a false alarm though a
raven
the jokester of the canyon
[Music]
there are far more serious threats from
below
squirrels know exactly how the
woodpecker banks work and are always
casing the joint and who could blame him
just look at all those acorns
this squirrel believes in sharing the
wealth but he better eat fast and stuff
those cheeks the woodpecker bank tellers
hit the alarm and the security guards
swing into action
[Music]
the bank is secured again but it won't
be long before the habitual thief tries
another stick-up
[Music]
you